welcome to this video and the system v
you are challenged let's play 55 minutes
0 so no increment and this is again the
Blitz writing other ratings not
comparable to the five-minute pool
system you will lead out much much
higher there so my 2550 is not that good
actually okay let's see we got the kinks
I've known the nizzle the names of
Indian zereshk on the board one of the
frequently played lines on my channel
are interesting this line what about you
for is this way why not come let's use
the center here Queenie to maybe the
some an idea or just a free as usual
calico let's keep it simple it's not
clear that the bishop on b7 is well
placed in any case quite often black
ones to play Bishop a 67 and oh it's
allowing me to pin I'll do that
maybe maybe I should have considered to
play a form but I kept I can still do it
now threatening e5 and this is also why
he cannot really take one see for now I
think quickly decided I thought it
wasn't possible really because of a five
but maybe there is some some trick
involved vago e5 takes takes Bishop d3
23 night if five not really i can take
the ahead
okay maybe I should still take here yeah
it's more precise 95 immediately was was
very possible d in 95 maybe was this was
possible but here I don't really have
any problem I just had them in this in
this awkward pin now fe5 has maybe even
more precise age six then if I go back
g5 efg takes h4 there must be must be
many good good ways to play Bishop takes
also not not bad but ok this is this is
the way to go the question is however
what now takes on f6 I just need green
g4 check and it's it's a mate basically
can I do something with the Queen
winning a tempo Queen d3 maybe queen d
through this okay takes on edge for 23
with the tempo and then quit f 32 g form
maybe this one but let's um think for a
moment maybe there is something
something very forcing available it
looks good though yeah that is going to
be this good this queen of three I mean
he I'm not sure what he moves now be
five or whatever be five men queen of
three the threatens queen reform and if
he goes kicking h7 there's queen e for
check and I can take h4 with the temple
this is really short decide if I can
keep the pawn here then this isn't a
defendable ready I don't think so yeah
just this check is the problem no here
with the temple and queen age 6 let's
let's see I'm covering this now so
not sure possibly rook h8 coming andrew
g a g6 this is in fact some sort of a
defense how to really win this
convincingly may be here winning a tempo
on the pawn and then look b3 using this
rook keeping the f1 rook active if he
takes I'm going to take with the night
trying to use it in their tech yeah I
think this was a good idea again I have
this time warnings check here check
check so I take the tick tonight then
maybe take it or get 93 in the attack
let me just here and down to 46 seconds
which is not really great
one group g 3n somehow but my g5 this
kind of stuff i can give the check out
and 94 i am check we cannot take that
because of Queen age six check made when
everyone I take your phone jack I have
Queen yet
check
check
check check check check who was asked
you I said why is this a maid he can't
take it check with them check check
check mate oh this wasn't a very
convincing realization of the advantage
when here lie it's like totally winning
and then I was right isn't totally
winning why isn't it computer is on 000
you want to if you want to want to kid
kid me here right the head with the porn
on a six ER 0 0 0 no way so 0.5 the
computer is giving this is quite
remarkable cannot really believe this I
know this is a mr. sly need to restart
this engine it's giving the same
evaluation absolutely the same
evaluation all the time which I really
don't believe this is super dangerous
isn't this is totally dangerous I
computer it's not agreeing I mean check
remarkable just giving all this is equal
check and not here check here it should
be a win for white but I screwed it up
really maybe not sure to a loss yet this
is losing Tweety a queen h7 it's a king
h7 that seems is holding no black also
has those checks him jack my own king
position was the problem here i'm
winning because this is check this is
leading to no I'm not winning this is a
drone actually wait check check check
what am i doing after this year this
Russia this is sorry I'm sure confusing
thanks to this was winning check T I can
take and become off because of shiny aid
check check check check yeah Queen h7 is
a mate I really overlooked that Queen
g4s a queen g3 is still possible g4 is
also made I was just thinking this is
also check mate but I we looked at the
Queen can take so bit of a lucky win but
the fun game I was really thinking that
Iran TM white is substantially better
than maybe this isn't a case really it's
quite surprising ok thanks for watching